[Music]
let's do it
okay 1368 from russia all right so i'm
going to jettison the bishop here with
bishop a3
all right i know i know you guys will
laugh but okay this is a serious
experiment so
okay i'm down a bishop all right i'm
down a bishop
now what do i do first of all you don't
want to go crazy and give up all the
rest of your pieces right you're already
down a piece and this is true also when
you blunder
i see this all the time somebody
blunders a piece and then they
immediately oh okay i'll sack the
rook in two rooks and i'll just pretend
this was a sacrifice let me lose the
game like two more moves
there's no need to you know own up to
your blunder right don't try to pretend
that you saw it
and i have really funny stories with
that and then sacrifice more pieces out
of some
sense of necessity now okay queen f3 now
what does he want what does he want
he wants to take on f6
and potentially he's
clearly trying to trade right but let's
use that to our advantage
right because here's what i notice folks
when he takes on f6 with his bishop
that rook on a1 is a little bit weird
and he's got a bunch of these dark
squares right around his position that
are kind of flimsy
so i'm going to go queen e7 here i'm
going to tempt him into taking on f6
because what i what that gives me the
chance to do
is take with a pawn why is taking with
the pawn good doesn't it
amen tie it seems like i'm ruining my
pawn structure
but this is actually potentially a
blessing in disguise because
what advantage does this pawn structure
give me
well first of all of course i avoid the
queen trade i mean i
can't trade queens
well it gives me the g file and i also
have the b file
so let's think about what i can do here
one thing that i can do here to try to
muddy the waters
right and win back some of this material
look at this pawn on e4
in the time that his king is still in
the center i can try to exploit that in
my favor by the way guys the move queen
e5
doesn't actually do very much due to
knight c3 so i can go either d5
or i can go f5 i can go either d5 or f5
i will go d5
i would have personally got f5 uh were i
playing alone but
uh this is a more thematic move and by
the way don't rush to take the pawn on
e4 because
taking the pawn on e4 notice opens up
the diagonal for his bishop
i want to take this pawn on my terms
what does that mean what move do i think
about playing then and this f5 right
we want to play f take c4 and establish
a pawn chain so that his bishop
remains locked up so we have already won
a pawn back and as people have indicated
we have that g-file
that we can use to stir things up on the
king's side
let's try to stir things up on the
king's side crook g8
no rocket science here i'm just trying
to do what i can i'm still lost i mean
king h1 he's very good
uh and the other thing is that despite
being down material that doesn't mean
we throw caution to the wind and we just
violate
all principles right we still want to
develop our pieces
uh and and we won't get any anywhere
without developing our pieces
and enhancing the quality of this pawn
chain
i do actually like the move f5 oh i
actually really like the move f5 so
let's actually go f5
to really just cement
our control over the center because
that's the only thing we have
but now let's develop our bishop
uh and potentially prepare castling long
although i don't think
i'm gonna do that okay now
i see an opportunity we can attack the
pawn on g2 and people have realized that
queen to g7 are right
now if he goes g3 that would already be
a mistake he's got to go queen g3
but that is not an easy move to find and
already
he is in a little bit of trouble because
if he goes g3 and i think he's realized
it
wow this guy is really good actually so
what do we do now
notice that the queen is the worst
defender the queen is the worst defender
i cannot repeat that enough what can we
do here
where can we go with our queen in order
to
keep yep queen h8 or we can go queen f6
right a little bit more
active uh hello grant uh well i would
ask the same of you
and and here's what's going on what's
going on
and queen h8 would have been actually
better now than i think about it
we're attacking his queen his queen is
on a very thin line with his knight
but if we go f4 and open up the attack
on the queen he has
knight takes e4 and i will explain that
after the game
so this is the time for us to do
what we need to make a move before we
play f4 and this move
we have prepared precisely for this kind
of eventuality
we need to castle we need to get our
king out don't worry i will explain this
after the game
why is f4 bad but this guy is extremely
underrated
he's seeing some pretty cool tactical
ideas okay
so he's got 92 well
we gotta throw our lots in the center of
the table let's go four
ooh there's a really cool idea
oh my lens oh my goodness there is a
really cool idea i'm just gonna make the
move right now and i will explain it
later
because i want him to think that we have
blundered our queen in reality
this is the other thing thank you
sicilian salad and joshua yalday for the
sub
oh my goodness now who can spot
who another queen sack who can spot the
sequence who can spot the sequence in
its entirety
fake bow test gambit it was a sacrifice
made in three what's the first move can
somebody give me the whole line
yes f takes g2 now what
we can even make a rook
double check forcing his king on to f1
and bishop h3 is
mate this is checkmate
all right so how did i come up with this
tactic well
here's the thing i will i will
make i mean that was a yeah i mean this
is a
cool tactic but honestly he should have
he should have suspected something
now well i appreciate it
yeah the hype is real
so yeah the guy is uh he's
i wonder what he's doing right now 100
bits thank you
uh kk detroit for the support uh he
could have done g3
but then i would have won my uh brought
my queen aside and
this pawn is very dangerous so
the the advice that i can share on the
basis of this is that you want to
when you've blundered when you're down a
piece you want your opponent to believe
that you're
basically tilted and blundering more
that's where these tactics come from
he feels like i'm tilted i'm down a
piece i don't know i played bishop a3 on
move two and so i'm blundering another
queen
you want to lull your opponent into that
sense
uh that you're just actually tilting and
blundering more pieces and
this is how you set traps right this is
not a prosaic trap it's actually quite
believable right he's like
okay this guy got fixated on these
threats on the king's side
he doesn't see the queen thank you
dugoterra for the for the two months
right um now the one thing
to point out in this position we all
wanted to play f4
opening up the attack on the queen but
the problem here is that i see
this x-ray right this is what bothers me
initially
and when we have an x-ray like this the
pawn on e4 is a
very very tenuous defender right it can
eat pawns can easily be eliminated thank
you dk runes for the prime
and it can be eliminated with the move
knight takes c4 counter-attacking the
queen
counter-attacking the queen if i take
his queen he takes mine it's a double
check
and he takes the rook and if i take on
e4
then he can either immediately take on
e6 with the queen and trade queens or he
can play rook takes c4
and the bishop is all his he's got three
attackers on it
and obviously it is pinned um
so what did i do in this game to create
chances what i realized is that
you can first identify what your
opponent is trying to do right it's
clear that he's trying to trade pieces
so why don't we use that to our
advantage right okay he's gonna train on
f6 but at least
i'm going to do what i can here to
create attacking chances rhyming get the
g file i'm going to get the possibility
of going d5
and so that's sort of how you do it you
try to spot these hidden drawbacks in
the way that your opponent is playing
you try to lull him into the sense that
you're tilted that you're not actually
calculating but in reality
that's how you've set the trap all right
why g3 is bad well g3 mean at the end so
what should he have done here
what he should have done is actually
taken on f3 i think
although things get very complicated
here already
the move g3 right is very logical
because if i take the knight now he
takes my queen there's no tactic in
sight if i take the queen
well then he succeeded in trading
queensies up a piece
i would have gone queen h6 here and um
look at the pawn on f3 right you can see
it
what kind of mate do you think about
when you see a pawn like this what is
the sort of tactical
um what tactical precedent does this set
yeah you think about the lobster pencil
mate white can go knight f4
right and he can protect the g2 square
with his knight but now maybe you go
bishop h3 and guess what
uh again there are some queen trades uh
some queen sacrifices in the air
and at the very least black can make a
draw here so
whenever you have a pawn like this on f3
uh that
just by definition by definition that
creates
a host a host
of tactical ideas uh that are not easy
to defend against not
not impossible but certainly not easy
um shwsa i use
chessbase which is a software that
anybody can purchase um i basically put
all of xqc's games in one database
uh and i ran a well chess base has a lot
of these functions you can
search basically all of white's all of
someone's games played with white
by frequency and i found that he played
the scotch
uh exclusively and so we went from there
um he should play queen g3 and he did oh
why is g3 bad there oh yeah
yeah so if he goes g3
the first thing that i see is this right
there's a queen and a knight and it's
spaced
one square apart what does this allow us
to do
what does this allow us to do yeah it
allows us to go d4
fork queen is defending now we want to
have the order of operations here
don't just grab the knight because the
bishop on e6 is hanging so we first take
b3
and then we take the knight and we've
won the piece back
okay so that's basically the reason why
he has to defend against the mate and
also stop the fork at the same time not
easy to do
oh we got another big donut 15 from mega
match 6969
thanks dania for all the great content
well it is my pleasure
thank you for the 15 donation i really
appreciate it all right
so that's basically that all right let's
play maybe
two more and then i will wrap up for
today
it is getting pretty darn late
so um any other questions oh queen h8
was better after queen g3
um no just scratch that i i thought
better of that
i thought so initially but it's not
worth explaining
what if he would have done e5 in the
first when
e51 here
spaniel well does it do you realize that
not everybody is in front of france
before i'm not sure where
i'm not sure where you're referring to
sorry instead of pawn g3 what about
knight to g3
uh also not sure what is being referred
to here so
sorry guys okay uh we're gonna we're
gonna proceed
um we're gonna proceed
and uh we're playing a 1450 so let's go
e4
and if he plays knight c6 we're gonna
play a rai lopez let's play ray lopez
um and he plays a steinitz which is
which is a line but it's quite passive
and in the right lopez you establish
this tension you establish this pit
uh but the rylopez works best if we have
central control
so we can play d4 but as you guys know i
like preparing
the move d4 with a preliminary move so
that we can
support our center with pawns and not
just have a reliance on the pieces
what move am i thinking about c3 yep
and we're gonna play d4 next he might
play a6 and then we're gonna drop our
bishop back
all right he got he goes bishop g4 i
don't care i'm gonna go db4
um now here we have an interesting
dilemma right we can go bishop a4 but
what i'm noticing is that we have all
this tension on this e5 pawn
so let's actually take his knight
ruining his pawn structure
now we're gonna chase his bishop away
with h3 and we're gonna yeah he's gonna
take we're gonna take with the queen and
let's take stock of what's happened here
okay so he's giving us the entire center
he has terrible pawn structure on the
queenside and he's not developed at all
neither are we for that matter but we
are ready to castle and he is not
so already i'm thinking about tactics
because
because he is very very far from
castling and that is a very dangerous
situation to be in
when you're this far from castling you
open yourself up to the possibility of
countless tactical ideas so we don't
want to go d5 we don't want to close the
center up in fact
we want to open the center up as much as
possible
which would mean what what do we do here
to open things up as much as possible
don't overthink it he has offered us
precisely the way to open up the center
the move c5 is terrible
and he makes his pawn structure even
worse
castles
and i will exp well the reason we don't
want to close the center as i explained
is because
we are the ones with the development
advantage we are the ones with the
development advantage and so we are the
ones
who would benefit from pieces getting
access to the opponent's king so
the time has come for concrete action
we can go rook d1 but the best is just
to go e5 and at some point you just have
to press the button
and sacrifice upon and open some stuff
up
um this is not such a big sacrifice to
where we really have to agonize over
it's just a pawn
and if he takes that pawn his bishop
lands on the same file as his rook so he
correctly
refrains from taking it but look at his
position this pawn is stopping his knife
from developing to f6
and the bishop is now stopping the
knight from developing to e7
we could give a check on c6 but but we
don't need to but we don't
actually need to and here's what i want
to show we're going to go rook d1 and
then we're just going to develop
i want to show that in many positions
just
simple development and simple adherence
to principles
reaps immediate benefit right okay thank
you very much and
it's checkmate right we didn't need to
give a check on c6 we didn't need to do
anything
all right so
the by the way the idea of knight c3 is
also to put a knight on d5 he is
completely paralyzed
so we don't need to force anything in
fact i think his king is a bit safer on
f8 than it is on e8
and um i don't see a point in putting
the queen on c6 as i've said many times
the queen is often best in a supporting
actress role
as the oscar sarah one called the
supporting actress sort of
in the shadows commanding the war rather
than on the front lines
you know getting caught up in uh
the other piece's hair okay uh
last game guys last game and then
analyze and then i will wrap
up once again we are white and we are
facing a karo khan so
uh i've played it very principally let's
play the advanced caro just the most
central opening
and we're gonna play this very simply
right we're just gonna we're gonna go
bishop d3 which is an under
underrated move by the way in the carl
and now we're going to
orchestrate a very interesting plan the
plan that we're going to aim for here is
attacking the base of the pawn chain
we're going to attack the base of the
pawn chain by
pushing up the f pawn but not
immediately not immediately
first we need to complete the
development of our king side so
knowing that the idea is to play f4 f5
where do you guys think i should put
this knight
yep 92 is correct and this is actually a
theoretical move
now what do we do here while i already
gave it away of course we don't want to
give up our pawn chain we go c3
cdcd so the idea of f4 is the plan but
first let's complete
all of our developments so that we don't
have to worry about that and then at our
leisure
we can start making sure that we get
that in so he's actually
playing this very well uh man these guys
are good
i'm telling these guys are good
particularly if he plays knight f5 right
now yeah he does
okay so he has thrown a bit of a
a um a wrench in the works here so
he's putting his knight precisely on the
square that we want to reach with our
pawn we don't want to allow that
so that will not do how do we get this
knight out of there
let's get this yeah he threw a danny
wrench so the idea that i want to apply
knight g3 is the correct idea but knight
iii blunders the pawn
so we first play bishop e3 and then we
play knight
iii we also tempt him into taking on e3
which would be a positional and tactical
mistake
all right which he doesn't make because
he is
helio bacha the famous now we're gonna
go knight g3 get the knight out of there
now here's the thing if he takes on g3
what are we gonna take with
okay what do we take with the queen of
the pawn and this is a very instructive
moment
think about the ultimate goal of the f
pawns push
precisely we take with the pun the
reason we take with the pawn
is because we open up the f-file and
that is a lot more important than the
double puns in addition
look at how nicely the d4 pawn is now
defended we don't have to worry about it
anymore whereas before
our pieces have the role of defending it
so how do we
how do we now kind of capitalize on this
open file what do we do
when we want to capitalize on a file not
a rook lift but a doubled
rook right we double the rooks we go
rook for rook f1 and where can this
knight on g3 potentially go
to increase the attacking potential of
our position
where can the knight go to increase the
tagging potential or position
there's really only one square so not a
big choice that i'm giving you precisely
knight h5
all right he takes on c3 i don't care
now the spawn on d4 is very nicely
reinforced
let's complete the doubling of our rooks
he's probably maneuvering his knight
over to g6 very very
strong play we're gonna go rook to g4 we
want our rook to remain
relevant and obviously g4 is the perfect
place to do that let's see what he does
no let's let's not throw up no i mean
this guy is playing very well
but um i'm not entirely so i'm a little
little bit
okay so because he's playing really well
uh this slightly changes how i play and
what does black want here what black
wants is to go queen c7 and win
our pawn on c3 i like the idea of h4 but
he can actually just take the pawn
you can actually just take well but we
can sacrifice it
hmm let's do it let's sacrifice the pun
now the idea of sacrificing with h4
is that when he takes on h4 the h file
becomes open
that doesn't seem important but more
important than the h1 we buy ourselves
time
to keep attacking we go knight h5 and
now he's got to go back to g6 and that
allows us the opportunity to lift the
other rook up to f3 and h3
this is probably unsound at a gm level
which uh i with every move i am
convinced that this guy is
but we'll see queen c7 now is what i was
concerned about but
this rook can double as a defender of
the pawn on c3 we could go e4
and reinforce the defense of the c3 pawn
so let's see how he handles the
situation
i could have i well i could have not
sacked the pawn i could have lifted the
rook up immediately
but this i feel like every tempo here is
important right he's going to start
pressuring us
on the queen side and so it's it's very
important to uh
to do things very efficiently um
no this guy is definitely legit he's
just very good um
yasser was not my teacher i i just had
one training session with him
uh but you know i'm on great terms with
him and i think very highly of him
so okay king h8 let's complete our rook
lift
and we actually have a really cool idea
potentially three games in a row of the
queen sacrifice
i'm gonna give you guys potentially
three games if he cooperates
and he just did we are about to have
three games in a row with a queen
sacrifice now wait a second
if we play queen takes g6 he takes with
the f
pawn but if he takes with the h pun then
we would have checkmate
so in what order do we take on g6
what should we do we play rook takes g6
f takes g6 then queen takes g6 and if he
takes our queen
knight f6 is gonna be checkmate
and that is a good way to end this
stream
in fact if he goes h6 we have knight f6
also nice by the way um just creating
massive threats against this king
yeah this is over um this is just over
now there's actually some very very nice
details here if he doesn't do anything
we have an even nicer well now we go
knight f6 that is the very typical
follow-up here
but i'll show you guys some nicer
details here as well
well sure it's been five hours and i
played a seven hour tournament before
the stream so
i'm right about ready but uh
yeah that's it 100 bits thank you kk
detroit appreciate it
um so by the way
uh let me just very quickly
one second no this guy is just good he's
just good
creepy crawlies come on man
uh so uh
if he did nothing right if he played
like rook c7
does anybody see the actual mating
sequence yes i have youtube and the
speedrun
is getting uploaded to the youtube and
i'm doing things as fast as i humanly
can
so it's not knight f6 that's the point
of rook c7
it's it's not knight f6 because now the
rook actually defends the pawn
you well beth harmon has to see this
queen takes h7
king takes h7 now g6 is the only escape
square which we take away with our
knight
and this is checkmate and this is
actually i actually think this is quite
quite pretty knight f4 the rook and the
the rook and the knight
combined trapping the king in the corner
so
if you don't think this is pretty then
then you don't like chess
but yeah this is uh this is a nice
combination just basically snapping
everything on g6
and if he takes then knight f6 is made i
mean actually we can go anywhere with
the knight
it's all good creepy crawlies i know
people are excited but
you know i need my two hours of sleep
okay um
chess can be beautiful says beth harmon
i agree
all right uh so that basically was the
game yeah you cannot go knight takes g7
because then the king takes uh takes on
on g7 so
it you know and and and this is the this
is the thing right when we come up with
a plan our opponent comes up with a way
to stop the plan
we want to approach that calmly right
and ask ourselves how can we get that
knight away from f5
well we go in ig3 but we can't go knight
g3 immediately because that would drop
t4
um okay so
uh there's more to analyze we have that
previous game
to look at but really nothing happened
other than this movie five which opened
up the center and i think most people
can understand
uh the purpose behind this move uh and
so we might
we visit this tomorrow but in the
meantime guys i will head to bed
thank you everybody for um
for for the incredible support today i
know that people want
you know people like the speedrun and
i'm very very happy to be doing it
uh particularly given the explosion of
viewers
uh so thank you everybody so very much
brought for
gem jam
[Music]
you